again not my body I don't know why they
didn't ask me I make this point every
time I wouldn't gladly come down for
that photoshoot but no they found an
intern on our staff that hasn't had a
meal in six years and clued that face to
it yeah you're very high-maintenance
they very just wanted to get through I
guess I guess so it's a lab skeleton all
right here we go
Fox and Friends I was watching Fox and
Friends as I do in the morning and then
I hit the info button to see what it
said it said learn the president's
opinions before he does then I was
watching I was watching NCIS
yeah I gotta love me some NCIS and I was
watching that and then I hit the button
and it said is this your favorite show
you might want to get your affairs in
order
like that I was watching this is us and
all that people watch this is us yeah
and then I was watching and I hit the
button and it said intense family stuff
interrupted by upbeat ads for rocket
mortgage I was watching Shahs of Sunset
you ever watched saws a sunset yeah I
was checking that out and then I hit the
button and it said see why Iran is
referred to as the long island of the
Middle East I was watching queer I
I was watching queer I yeah and then I
hit the button the button said what if
stay with me a straight guy war ah ha
I was watching The Price is Right yes
watching The Price is Right and then I
hit the button and it said people who
love refrigerators win them see that
woman that's the happiest I've ever seen
anybody a battery I mean I'm sure it's a
nice refrigerator but that woman just
lost her mind
it refrigerate warm things become chill
Dancing with the Stars I was watching
Dancing with the Stars and then I hit
the button said this year's winner gets
to be White House chief of staff
bachelor in paradise I was checking out
bachelor in paradise guy check that show
out then I hit the button the button
said chlamydia with live
and then finally I'm watching $100,000
pyramid yeah watching that and I hit the
button and it said gameshow finds
desperate people who'll do anything to
win enough money to quit their crappy
job
you
you